all right what's good Budapest oh we are
do that again how's it going Budapest
better b-plus good job all right
hi my name is Vita he um and I want to
kind of get a sense of the room how many
of you grew up hearing oh this is good I
was not used I'm not used to like
looking up but I you are all here I'm
gonna look up more often all right how
many of you grew up hearing fairy tales
as a kid all right
good that's good because this talk
probably is not gonna make sense if you
didn't so I'm glad I bet on that
how many of you have heard the fairy
tale Goldilocks and the three bears okay
most everybody for those of you who
haven't a quick plot summary the story
of Goldilocks and the three bears is
basically that there's this girl named
Goldilocks and she breaks into a house
in the woods I don't know why she's in
the woods but she's there and she breaks
into this house and she like it's
totally abandoned like nobody is at home
and it turns out this is the house of
three bears and she like tries out all
their stuff like she sleeps in their bed
and she eats their porridge and like the
Papa bear's porridge is too hot and the
mama bears porridge is too cold and the
whole story is like her basically going
through people's stuff or bear stuff and
it's like in retrospect as an adult I
realize it's probably not a wise thing
to teach children like if it was
Goldilocks and the three bunny rabbits
probably better but three bears
feel like I don't know I don't think
that's the best thing but needless to
say I did some research on Goldilocks
and the three bears and it turns out
that this fairytale dates back to the
year 1837 so it's over 150 years old and
I got to thinking about what Goldilocks
and the three bears would be like with a
modern day twist if we were to tell that
same story what would that story be like
and that's what we're gonna do today
so modern-day Goldilocks she doesn't
break into houses anymore she's over
that she learned her lesson instead
modern-day Goldilocks is a JavaScript
available developer obviously cuz why
wouldn't she be and modern-day
Goldilocks is working at her first dev
job and she loves it so she's writing
JavaScript she's like working with
frameworks like angular and ember and
even a little react and she's having a
great time because she's learning a lot
from the other developers on her team
and this company that she's working at
it's pretty small she's the first junior
developer that they have and she gets to
ask a lot of questions and learn a lot
from these other developers by writing
code that's in production which is the
first time she's ever done that so
that's really exciting but after like
six months of being at this company she
realizes that they're definitely some
places where this company has drawbacks
so after about six months she starts
wondering am I actually getting better
at writing code
I don't know and she talks to other
developer friends of hers and she finds
out that at other companies one of the
ways that a lot of junior developers
realize that they're getting better or
learn what they can improve on and get
feedback is through the process of code
so Goldilocks gets to thinking and she
realizes we don't actually have any
formal code review process at my company
in fact whenever I want review I have to
ask another engineer to look at my code
and if I forget what I did wrong on like
a feature or like something that I could
have improved on I don't have that
feedback written down or documented
anywhere and she starts to think about
whether this is like going to be a
long-term sustainable place for her to
stay and she realizes after talking to
other developers that even junior
developers on other teams can understand
and learn from what senior developers
are working on by reviewing their code
and at her company they're not doing any
of that so it's not great and after
about a year or so
Goldilocks decides I've learned a lot
here but it's time for me to move on and
she goes to her second dev job so at her
second dev job things are different and
one of the things that's very very
different from her first step' job is
the fact that they take code reviews
pretty seriously every single PR that is
made at this company on this engineering
team is reviewed which she's like that's
awesome that's exactly what I was
looking for now I'll finally get like
the feedback that I need and I'll learn
and I'll make fewer mistakes and I'm
gonna grow it's gonna be great on her
first week at this new job she's super
excited because she gets to review the
CTOs code so now she's doing things that
she couldn't do before and this is
really exciting but after about 6 or 7
months again she realizes that even this
company has its drawbacks
they have code review processes but it's
small
it's a small team it's a small start-up
and really their process is just as long
as one person gives it a thumbs up that
code can be merged in and like sometimes
those PRS will devolve intellect long
discussions or many comments and
sometimes they're debating like do we
want to put a semicolon here she'll use
tabs and spaces you know those types of
discussions but the code review process
is working fine and they're merging code
in there merging a lot of code in and
everything is fine and it seems to be ok
until one day so one day Goldilocks
decides that she's finally ready to
merge in this feature that she's been
working on and she's been working on it
for like three weeks and she's like okay
good to go she merges it in and before
she merges it it's reviewed it's
reviewed by two other engineers on the
team and then she's like okay I'm gonna
push this to staging and I'm gonna go
get a coffee she gets back from getting
her coffee and 20 minutes later she
walks into the office and everyone is
having a minor panic attack because the
code that she merged in totally broke
staging and the entire environment is
down so everybody's like Goldilocks what
did you do what did you deploy and she's
like I mean you looked at the code I
don't know what I did wrong we all
reviewed it but not to be deterred
Goldilocks
sets out to try to put out this fire and
figure out what she did wrong as it
turns out she made a pull request with
two files that were named the same and
one of them had code in it and one of
them was totally empty and she
Adelita except she forgot to delete it
and nobody caught that and then a whole
of staging went down and everybody
freaked out and when she sees this
mistake and she sees that nobody on her
team caught this mistake she gets to
thinking and she's like oh no we really
thought that we had this code review
thing down but maybe we don't and she
realizes that these two teams that she's
worked on she's been looking for this
perfect balance of which code review
workflow works the best and she doesn't
really know if she's found it yet so she
does what probably all of us in this
room would do in this situation she
asked the internet and she does some
googling and she hears about this really
ancient book called
code complete and she starts thinking oh
my god there must be a better way of
doing code reviews right so she decides
to dive into the theory of code reviews
and she opens up this book called code
complete which is so old it dates back
to the Year 1993 so I mean like really
old and she reads a lot of the theory
and research behind code reviews code
complete was written by a man named
Steve McConnell it's a really great book
and I recommend it to all of you to pick
up and he's done a lot of research in
this book Goldilocks Pines and it turns
out that there are three different types
of code reviews that came about in about
the late 80s and they're kind of the
fundamental core of the code reviews
that we do today theoretically
and so she seeks to understand why did
we start doing code reviews and what are
they
good for what is the ideal code review
process supposed to be like because if I
can understand that then maybe I can
bring it to my team and try to improve
our process so encode complete Steve
McConnell writes this one part of
managing a software engineering process
is catching problems at the lowest value
stage that is at the time at which the
least investment has been made and
problems cost the least to correct the
idea that Steve McConnell try it kind of
gets that in this book is that code
reviews should act as quality gates for
our code code bases similar to if we
create a product and we test it and we
check its quality through QA or generic
testing in general code reviews should
act as similar gates for our code bases
so she starts thinking about this and
she's like I don't know if our team's
code review process like if our code
review our quality gates are actually of
good quality sometimes it feels like
we're just doing it as a formality so
she keeps reading and she finds that the
most effective code reviews according to
research are the ones that are based on
this idea of the collective ownership of
construction which is the idea that if
all of us have a hand and all of us have
an investment in our code base and we
feel like we're building it together
then code reviews actually improve the
lifespan of our code base so one of the
examples that Steve McConnell gives is
that if you have more sets of eyes on
your code base through code reviews this
might seem obvious but your code base
will actually get better because you
have more people looking at it another
great benefit
is the fact that if someone leaves your
team the rest of the team can still pick
up and function because even if they
haven't written the code that that
person wrote who left they've at least
reviewed it so they're somewhat familiar
with the problems that they were working
on and the features that they built in a
similar vein being able to detect bugs
and solve them is a lot easier for
anyone on the team if you've reviewed
code that you might have not necessarily
written these are cycles of defect
correction so when you identify
something that's problematic in the code
whether it's a bug or a design flaw and
you can actually fix those things faster
through code reviews but what are the
different types of code reviews
Goldilocks is sold she's like okay
all this theory seems great but like
what different types of code reviews
were created because she doesn't really
know about the history of code reviews
as it turns out one of the earliest
instances of code reviews dates back to
the 70s and there was a small team at
IBM that started implementing something
called inspections this was basically a
kind of long form code review where
three people would come into a room the
person who wrote the code the person who
was reviewing the code and a moderator
and all three of them would come in with
this checklist of things that they had
looked for and things that they were
accountable while reviewing the code and
the idea was that you would look at the
code and look for possible defects
within it so it might be design flaws or
bugs or other things that might be
problematic when you merge that code
into the larger code base and the idea
was that you weren't trying to
necessarily fix the code in that moment
you are just trying to look for gaping
holes
so inspections were very long types of
code reviews that took 30 to 60 minutes
but as Goldilocks found there is another
type of code review as well and these
are short reviews short reviews
basically hinge on the idea that back in
the 70s and even early 80s a lot of
teams were not reviewing code and
especially not reviewing code that was
like one or two line changes and Steve
McConnell did some research on this and
encode complete he writes about how
teams that started checking code and
reviewing it when it was under a five
line change saw drastic results so one
of the examples he gives is that there
was a team that had a 55% error rate in
their code base and they started
implementing short reviews where even if
he was a one line change they would make
sure that code was reviewed and that
team went from a fifty five percent
error rate to a two percent error rate
which is kind of wild if you think about
it in a similar vein there was another
engineering team that had an 86 percent
correctness rate and once they
implemented short code reviews they went
from an 86 percent correctness rate to
ninety nine point six so this was kind
of a game changer in the world and the
theory of code reviews like 30 or so
years ago the third type of code review
that she reads about sounds similar to
things that she's experienced with
senior engineers on her team and this is
something called a walkthrough
walkthroughs are basically working
meetings so the idea is that you have
like a senior engineer and maybe a more
junior a mid-level engineer and the two
of them sit down and they talk about the
design decisions made in the code in a
code change and things that could
possibly go wrong or things that maybe
could be reconsidered
refactored in a different way in Steve
McConnell's research he found that
walkthroughs aren't as effective but
they can have some benefits they can
reduce up to 30% of errors and programs
but they're more learning opportunities
then opportunities to actually find tons
and tons of bugs in your code and as
she's reading Goldilocks stumbles upon
something called the peer-review
sophistication scale and this is
something that has been around since the
late 70s and early 80s back when code
reviews were kind of getting formulated
and the idea was that any engineering
team could look at this and kind of self
assess where they fell on this review
sophistication scale and as Goldilocks
looks at this she starts thinking I
don't think I've ever worked on a team
that's been a for probably not even a
three and she's like is it just me has
everybody else got code reviews down or
is like is everyone else feeling the
same discontentment with code reviews
and she's read a lot of the theory but
she doesn't feel like she's able to
debug what went wrong in her team's code
review process so she decides to take
theory and build on it one level further
she decides to actually figure out what
code reviews are like in the industry in
practice so she does what most of us
would do she asked the internet
specifically she asked Twitter which
sometimes goes well and sometimes does
not go well but she basically asked
everyone hey I'm collecting data on code
reviews can you tell me what you think
and what she finds is really interesting
so she starts
looking at this data and a quick
disclaimer about this data she is not a
data scientist so it's obviously not a
great representation of the entire
industry for one thing people who
answered the survey are only gonna be
people who saw her tweet and
self-selected into it but it's still
better than nothing so she decides to
see what she can learn from this data
even if it might not be the most
accurate it's a start so the first
things she finds is that the majority of
people who answered her survey worked in
Java in Ruby and rails and in JavaScript
and she asked them a few quality dove
questions and a few quantitative
questions so the first thing she asked
was half code reviews personally made
you a better developer because you can't
really assume that it's helped everybody
so she wants to be sure and it turns out
most people tend to tended to agree with
her the average answer for code reviews
have made me a personal developer on a
scale of one to ten was about an eight
point six so it seemed like most people
felt like code reviews were a good thing
for them personally and she saw that
most people found code reviews
beneficial to their entire team and the
interesting thing about this was that it
wasn't like just JavaScript developers
or just Java developers or Swift
developers everybody seemed to agree
that having code reviews on their team
was a good thing for the entire team and
their codebase however she did notice
that most people have engineering teams
that had code reviews as a requirement
but there was still about around 10% of
people who had to request review so it's
not like all teams had code reviews as a
formality there were still some team
that were merging code without ever
actually having it reviewed but it was
interesting because her data seemed to
suggest that it didn't really matter
what language or framework you worked in
rather whether your team implemented
code reviews as a actual part of your
workflow or whether they didn't had
nothing to do with your language and
instead everything to do with your team
dynamics your framework has nothing to
do with how well your code review
process is actually contributing to your
codebase but rather it's you and your
teammates was Goldilocks his guess
interestingly she found that most teams
only required one person to actually
review the code there were some team may
be around 20% 7% that said I need two to
three people to review my code but for
the most part one person was enough but
people could wait up to five to twenty
minutes or even sometimes like up to an
hour spending that time to actually
review code for the most part though no
one was spending more than an hour
really reviewing a pull request people
didn't really want to spend too much
time they wanted to like do it very
quickly and it seemed like most people
had to wait a few hours until code was
actually reviewed by one of their peers
so people weren't spending too much time
reviewing what people had to spend a
decent amount of time waiting for
someone else to review this COIs all of
this qualitative data or quantitative
data was fine but Goldilocks was really
interested in reading the results of her
qualitative data so part of her survey
was asking very broad open-ended
questions and the responses that she got
from other developed
we're really interesting she started
reading through the responses and she
saw that there were two main things two
main characteristics that would either
make or break a code review and these
two characteristics can kind of be
summarized as energy and substance so
when we say energy what do we mean well
energy really boils down to who is doing
the code review and how much time are
they spending on it it seemed like a lot
of people would either hate their code
review process or love it based on the
amount of energy that was spent on the
code review workflow one developer Roden
and they said it's not just the act of
doing a code review everyone on the team
should receive equal review I feel like
it's so common for senior people to get
no feedback because people assume they
can do no wrong they totally can and
senior people might want feedback junior
people get nitpick to death and people
forget that self-esteem is likely to be
affected and people are being vulnerable
when they submit a code review someone
else wrote in and they said code reviews
need to be acknowledged as first-class
citizens in a dev team they need to be a
legitimate activity that requires time
and focus and it was interesting because
it seemed like some people on certain
teams really felt strongly about code
reviews and other people didn't and that
would very much leave a sour taste in
their colleagues mouths
one person wrote in and said we have one
developer who blindly thumbs up every
pull request and rarely leaves comments
they're trying to game the rule of at
least two approvals and it's easy to
tell because inside of one minute
they've approved two to three pull
requests someone else said the second
and third people to review a PR are more
likely to have a rubber stamp of
approval after seeing someone else
without actually reading the code so
some of the overarching themes that
Goldilocks notice was that things like
very large commits or very large PRS
with no context would make people more
likely to give a thumbs up without
actually reading the code and things
that really really got under some
developers skin was the fact that not
everybody on the team was reviewed
equally unequal reviews seem to be a
theme that came up again and again in
her survey data and there were a lot of
developers who wrote in and said I want
to do code reviews more but our upper
management doesn't think that they're
important when they're like second-class
citizens so we can't spend the time that
we want to spend reviewing code
Goldilocks kept reading and she saw that
the idea of substance was something else
that came up a lot so when we say
substance what we mean is what exactly
are people saying or doing while
reviewing it's fine if everybody reviews
and is reviewed equally but what they're
saying and how they're saying those
things really matters so one developer
answered her survey and they said this
if I ever find myself going back and
forth on something in comments on a pull
request
I'll ping the other person and ask them
to pair sometimes it's just really hard
to talk to someone another developer
wrote this we need to review the code
and not the person we should let tools
handle styling changes for us so that we
as a team don't need to spend time on
this and another developer wrote in and
said that on their team people actually
trolled each other's code in pull
requests and there is no code of conduct
so there was no way to enforce if people
were actually being kind to one another
or not and what was really interesting
was as she read through some of these
comments she just did like a quick find
and file through all of her survey data
and she saw that around 5% of people who
responded actually used the word nitpick
when talking about code reviews they had
such a negative reaction to people
picking on their code and doing it in a
really unkind way so some of the themes
that she took away was that people got
really really frustrated and irritated
when pull requests would turn into lots
and lots of comments and it seemed like
people would rather just have a
conversation with another human rather
than leaving comments on a pull request
the nitpicking thing came up again and
again and it seemed like pull requests
that turned into a free-for-all where
everybody's focusing on style and syntax
was just generally something that was
going to lead to a really negative code
review experience and this was
particularly the case for people who
were more junior or new in the field but
the biggest one was developers who wrote
in anonymously and said all of my
negative experiences with code reviews
have stemmed from situations when
someone has been egotistical and
see empathy whether they were the one
being reviewed or they were the one
doing the reviewing so as Goldilocks
look through all this data she realized
that there was kind of a disconnect
between the theory of code reviews and
what was actually happening in practice
and the disconnect was that nobody was
talking about what was being done in
practice and whether it was actually
working people were going through the
actions and a lot of teams were
implementing code reviews but based on
all of this data from engineers who
worked in all these languages a lot of
people weren't happy with it so there
was this strange disconnect between what
code reviews were meant to be and how
they were actually functioning in the
industry today and the biggest problem
she saw was that nobody was talking
about it she had felt so alone in her
own team that she thought it was just
her but now she realized it wasn't it
was all the people around her too so I
started this talk by saying that this is
a fairy tale and this is modern-day
Goldilocks I haven't been entirely
honest with you because I'm Goldilocks
surprised these days I actually don't
work at either of those two companies I
work at a company called tilde in
Portland and we build a product called
sky life which is a profiler for rails
applications but some of you might know
tilde as the creators of ember and to
tell you the truth since we're being
honest I don't actually know if we've
got our code review process down I'm
sure there are things about it that are
still problematic
but what I do know is that every single
person on our team feels comfortable
talking about it in fact one of my
colleagues actually submitted an RFC to
totally change our code review process
because they were so frustrated with the
way that I was working they were like we
should do this differently and they
wrote a proposal and everybody in our
company looked at it and reviewed it and
we ended up changing how we did code
reviews and it's something that we still
discuss often whenever it comes up as a
point of contention so based on all of
this research that I collected and all
of the things that I've learned about
code reviews over this past year I
wanted to share a couple things that
I've learned are small wins that you can
do that you can take back to your team
and a couple big ones too so let's start
with a small stuff first a really easy
way to make your code review process
better is by using commit hooks so I
recently learned about something called
Huskie which I haven't actually used but
I've heard good things about which
allows you to basically create commit
hooks so that things like running tests
or linters or anything that needs to
happen before creating a pull request
even before making the plural requests
before you commit you can make sure all
of those little things are taken care of
so that you never have a pull request
that devolves into comments about how
something didn't happen that should have
happened before the pull request was
made another small win github has an
amazing feature where you can actually
create PR templates so here's our PR
template that we use and sidenote
awesome full request is a terrible name
don't have our name your pull request
that there's no context in that but
basically all of the things that we
expect every single pull request to have
we create that and add it as part of the
template my favorite thing about our
template is the section that says this
pull request is required before you can
merge it the authors have to be proud of
it
which i think is really important
acknowledging the positive things in a
code review and in the code that's being
added not just the things that you know
could use some constructive criticism
another great thing is using screenshots
or gifs if you give your colleagues
context of what's happening in your pull
request whether it's fixing a bug or
adding a new feature they're less likely
to look like confused puppies when
they're looking at your code because
you've given them all the context that
they need linters
you should just use them they're awesome
and you will never have a discussion
about what syntax your team wants in a
pull request because you've already
agreed upon what linter styles and what
you want to adopt and not use ahead of
time so nobody ever needs to feel
nitpicked and your code review process
can actually focus on larger things that
don't involve things that could be fixed
with a linter another great thing is
encapsulating pull requests into smaller
bite-sized things I like to think of how
we're always talking about encapsulating
code into like little you know packages
that are like small contained don't
necessarily lean on a lot of other
things in a similar way if you make a
pull request that is encapsulated and
provides context it's a lot easier for
people to look at this isolated thing
and then the barrier to entry for
reviewing your pull request is a lot
lower people are gonna be less likely to
wait until the end of the day because
it's an encapsulated small pull request
with obvious commits and it's a lot
clearer for someone to see what you're
trying to do if you have a team that
this actually can work for having
specific reviewers can be really awesome
so if you have specific reviewers you
can ensure that everybody on the team is
actually getting reviewed and is being
reviewed equally and it helps distribute
the workloads so that it's never just
one or two people reviewing code
everybody is taking that on and it
really helps the idea of collective
ownership of a codebase so big ones a
lot of little things you can do but
these take a little bit more time but in
my opinion they're really worth it so in
reviewing everyone equally part of that
is pushing for a larger culture on your
team we're gonna bill 'ti is actually
valued
this is hard to do because it involves
changing the languages you use in pull
requests and in you know even in
conversations about code and slack or
something like that it involves changing
how you talk to each other on the team
and perhaps that it involves refocusing
on reviewing a person to reviewing the
code which can be hard to do and takes
time but it's really worth it and can
totally change the dynamic for everybody
on the team regardless of skill level
developing empathy so you saw an example
of this in our RP our template but
making a habit of calling out the good
stuff in a code review is super
important a lot of the times people feel
that code reviews are just really
negative and that you're putting
yourself out there to be vulnerable that
people are gonna jump on and attack all
the things you did but if you changed
the paradigm of your code review flow so
that people are also equally calling out
all the awesome things that someone did
they're gonna feel more confident in
being vulnerable with their team mates
again hard to do but worth it this one
was the most important iterate it's so
important I'll say it again it's her
rate and what I mean by this is start a
conversation if you feel like your code
review flow isn't working well and if
it's not working well after six months
or things are going maybe not as
smoothly as you'd like have a
conversation about it again maybe
introduce a process where someone can
write an RFC or someone can anonymously
send a message in slack about something
that might not be working for them in
the code review process or discuss it in
your retros if you have them the most
important thing you can do and the thing
that I hope all of you will take away
from this talk is to have a conversation
about whether your code review process
is actually working
I hope you'll reflect on whether your
quality gates are actually of good
quality because if I've learned anything
in researching and talking to other
developers about code reviews it's that
a lot of us are unhappy and we're just
not talking about it hopefully we will
and I think this quote which somebody
wrote in to the survey really summarizes
it better than I ever could
they said I love code reviews in theory
in practice they are only as good as the
group that's responsible for conducting
them in the right manner the hard stuff
about code isn't the code it's the
people who write the code and code
reviews are kind of the intersect
intersection of the humans who write the
code and the code that they write we
could all do a little bit better job of
making sure that we respect the humans
that are involved in making software
that we all consume and use so if you
are interested in learning more about
code reviews or if you'd like to
contribute to the survey you can go to
better code reviews and there's also a
much longer in-depth written version of
this talk that you can go to and fitly
better code reviews and thank you so
very much for your time you've been an
awesome audience